injustice gods among us was not
a very good movie
here's the reason why i don't want to be
one of these guys who says that the
movie sucks because it didn't follow the
storyline down to a t right there were a
lot of similarities there the reason why
the injustice movie was bad is because
it missed everything that made injustice
significant and justice was a
philosophical story and in fact a lot of
people misinterpret who exactly it is
that injustice is critiquing but let's
let's kind of break this down for a
second right so in terms of the movie
the catalyst behind it all is the exact
same as it is in the comics that
basically joker tricks superman into
killing lois lane and their unborn child
in response to that superman freaks out
kills the joker and then basically turns
the justice league minus batman into
what's basically an autocratic governing
body ruling the world on the surface
that sounds like a pretty villainous
thing to do but once you start getting
into the philosophical reasons as to why
it happens it actually makes sense right
so let's talk about batman and suit man
for a second because honestly one of the
most disappointing things in the in the
animated movie you never see them fight
i don't know why but there were a few
things that were pretty significant here
right so batman and superman and at
least in terms of this story have two
completely and totally diametrically
opposing views so on one side batman
believes in a no killing rule right and
he's like peacemaker from suicide squad
he doesn't care how many men women and
children have to die in order for him to
maintain that no killing rule and then
on the other hand you have superman who
says no there are some people out there
who are just so incorrigible that the
only way to deal with them is to kill
them right the joker's a perfect example
of that the whole idea behind that is
the joker leaving gotham city showing up
in metropolis and then basically
instigating a series of events that
leads to superman killing his wife and
his unborn child that's batman's fault
and no better moment in the entire
injustice comic series highlights that
than when they first meet after superman
kills the joker there's this great big
huge argument that goes on in the
batcave you saw it to a degree right but
the best thing about this is that they
get into it right i mean they're just
it's a full-blown argument here and the
whole stance that batman has is we have
to be better and you superman we're
supposed to be the best of us this
incorrigible incorruptible person who
could never fall prey to the failings of
humanity that you were the one who
inspired not only many of the superhero
community to become superheroes but the
one that would lead the world into going
to a better direction the response to
superman is what happened to me happened
because of you batman because how many
innocent people have died because you
let the joker go that batman knew the
joker could not be held by the criminal
justice system he knew the criminal
justice system is corrupt he knew that
it was easy for the joker to escape he's
done it so many times before and every
time the joker escapes he goes on a
killing spree sometimes it's dozens
sometimes it's thousands depending on
what story you're reading but the joker
always goes on a killing spree batman
snatches him up he hands them over to
the authorities the authorities can't
hold him the joker escapes and the cycle
repeats itself and the argument superman
presented here is if you knew that
wasn't the case and you knew the joker
escaping would lead to him killing
people then you willingly sacrificed
human lives because you thought it was
wrong to kill the joker no he needed to
die he had to die because he couldn't be
fixed he couldn't be saved there was no
way to make him better and in your
foolish pursuit of this ideology of not
killing people you sacrificed thousands
of innocent lives so in a lot of ways
you're worse than i am but at the end of
the day batman stays strong and says no
that it doesn't work that way we cannot
be judge jury and executioner and that's
when the critique of everything comes
into play so here's what's really really
cool about this right there's a movie
called kill bill that i'm sure some of
you guys have seen some of you guys
haven't in that movie or at least in the
second movie there's this phenomenal
moment where bill has this monologue and
he explains the nature of superman what
bill says in this is that a staple of
the superhero mythos is that you have
the superhero and you have the alter ego
that batman is really bruce wayne
spider-man is peter parker that when
those characters get up in the morning
they're bruce wayne and they're peter
parker and it's in that characteristic
that superman stands alone that superman
didn't become superman superman was born
superman the outfit that he wears with a
big red s that's what he was wearing
when the kids found him those are his
clothes the glasses and the business
suit that's the costume that's the
costume superman wears to blend in with
us that clark kent is how superman sees
us and what are the characteristics of
clark kent right bill says clark kent is
weak he's unsure of himself
he's a coward that clark kent is
superman's critique on the whole human
race now take that concept and
extrapolate it out into the injustice
mythos right that when superman kills
the joker that was one part anger over
the fact that joker tricked him into
killing his wife and his unborn child
and the other part of it was pragmatism
that it was just time right that the
joker just needed to go like it just he
just needed to die because there was no
conceivable way to fix or save this guy
and batman believing it could be done
was just wide-eyed childhood optimism
right living in a fantasy land instead
of in the real world and then at that
point superman's entire gaze turns into
the rest of humanity and that's the
critique that's what made injustice so
cool injustice gods among us is not a
critique of the failure of batman
because of his no killing rule or the
fact that superman became corrupted and
conquered the world it's a critique on
humanity it's a critique on people that
superman did what he did because people
just didn't fix anything right that in a
world that is largely governed by
presidents and you know sentence and all
that kind of stuff right official
governing bodies who in turn are largely
elected by people that there's war and
there's chaos and there's robbery and
death and destruction and that when it
all came down to it like very much what
we see in the real world it's reddit
posts twitter hashtags but no one ever
actually doing anything to fix anything
and so the response is or at least this
process superman is if the world won't
make itself better then i will i will
fix the world right humanity had its
chance right these people that exist in
these societies they had their chance to
fix things and they didn't whether it
was because of lazy incompetence
complacency or all of the above whatever
the case happened to be they didn't want
to fix anything well if they won't then
i will i will make things better and so
that's when superman starts traveling
around the world and has like like
instructs these cease-fires right like
if you as governments do not fix this if
you do not stop fighting i will destroy
you all and then there'll be nothing
left of anybody to fight so either you
can rule in peace or you can die in
chaos one of those two options but it's
gonna be one now while all this was
happening it wasn't enough to show
superman doing this that wouldn't really
be very eventful right superman just
ending conflicts among governments by
threat or anything along those lines
superman's parents being kidnapped by
the president which is one of the
dumbest things he could have done it
wouldn't be enough to show that what you
need is a counterweight you need us as
the audience in the story and while you
had batman who was basically leading
what you would call insurgents those
individuals who defected from superman
who thought he was doing the wrong thing
sided with batman and just taking pot
shots where they could some of whom died
some of whom continued on the whole
thing behind this is you had the flash
and that's one of the things the movie
screwed up so bad because the flash gone
like that right i mean he's dead in the
first 10 minutes and it blew balls
because you had mr terrific there but at
the end of the day barry allen should
have been that guy because barry allen
in a lot of ways is the character in the
comics who sways back and forth he's us
he is torn he doesn't know who to side
with is batman correct is batman right
and saying superheroes shouldn't be
forming some kind of autocratic
governing body to control the world but
at the same time he looks at superman
and says but did the inaction of society
itself the laziness complacency or
ineptitude of society did they force
superman's hand did they put him in a
position to where because they weren't
willing to fix anything that he was
going to fix it is superman right are
there some beings out there who just
can't be fixed and have to die and a lot
of arguments get brought up there right
the chess game you saw in the animated
movie that was between the flash and
superman and one of the coolest things
about that is that whole conversation
happens at super speed they're just
moving like super fast it's cool but all
the points that mr terrific brought up
is basically the same thing that
superman brought up but through it all
even though barry is explaining this
perspective he still struggles because
you have what's called the slippery
slope argument but the slippery slope
argument is an argument you present when
you don't have any other argument
because the slippery slope argument
assumes that you can't stop yourself
that what you're doing is a compulsion
that you can't simply say this is the
line in the sand this is where we stop
and that's an absolute line done there's
no justification beyond doing that like
you do what is an effect following the
philosophy of superman which is the
needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few and the argument that barry
allen was producing was saying okay so
like if you're gonna reach a point where
you're basically going to arrest people
for petty things for things that don't
really matter for things that aren't
important because you want to make sure
they're following the law that you
create and so that's what's kind of
interesting about that is over the
course of the whole injustice series
barry is conflicted he's like us he
doesn't know which side to go with he
doesn't know who's really right here now
a lot of that really comes to a head
with a character that was totally left
out of the animated movie called galaxin
right this was a kid who had basically
idolized the justice league and in fact
he was the flash's biggest fan but he
had idolized superman and wonder woman
and batman and the flash he saw them as
these beings who always championed and
did what was right but there came a
point when superman became this kind of
dictator that when he showed up in a
town and was like we're ruling this
whole place with an iron fist that kind
of a thing that galaction stood up to
superman and got absolutely pummeled now
it's not until he's beaten within an
inch of his life that you actually find
out the whole idea that he was a big fan
of the justice league and then you're
told later on down the line that he
basically killed himself they undid that
injustice 2 which i wasn't really the
biggest fan of but you end up learning
the kid killed himself because of his
experience because it was just so
traumatizing for him but then you also
had black adam and that was a great
concept because you had shazam and you
had wonder woman who showed up on the
doorstep of black adam and kondok and
said superman's rule is going to be
absolute will you ally yourself with
superman and because black adam's whole
allegiance is to his people in his
kingdom come what may he'll let the
world burn before he lets anybody and
con doc experience any kind of pain or
suffering the response he gives is i'm
fine as long as superman doesn't show up
here if superman shows up in conduct and
tells me that i have to follow his rule
of law no we'll go to blows i will fight
superman and so what they do is they
force him to transform back into his
human form and he dies but like there's
a point there where he begs billy batson
to protect his people to keep his people
safe it's things like that you learn
over the course of the comic book series
that like harley quinn had a daughter
that she had to give up it's just stuff
like that there's so much character
development there that expands on the
individual characters and while that may
in and of itself not be the most
important thing the fact that the
characters are carrying around the
weights of their own individual
struggles their own backstories their
suffering adds even more gravitas to
what's going on because now they have to
make this moral choice between batman or
superman which one is right which one of
these guys is making the right call the
the injustice comic series was just
phenomenal but i still stick by the idea
that what made injustice so great is
that it was a critique of people it was
a critique of the ineptitude and the
laziness and the apathy of the average
person when it came to fixing anything
wrong right it was people who were just
like something needs to be done
i mean somebody else will do it but like
something needs to be done right like
you know raising awareness like there's
a problem there
somebody also fixed it but i i did my
job i told people there was an issue
there right that kind of a thing right
that sure it sounds nice and it's a
great way to pat yourself on the back
but like standing on a street corner
with a sign for a day and a half and
doing nothing isn't going to fix
anything and so the whole critique about
that is people people were the problem
they forced the hand of superman because
somebody had to make the world better
and they weren't going to and so again i
loved injustice gods among us all that
was missed over the course of the of the
animated film the animated film it was
it felt just so redundant right it was
basically just like well batman and
superman are fighting each other because
superman's wife and and his unborn kid
were killed by the joker and so now
they're fighting and then here comes
razal ghoul with the amazo android and
now that's the main villain and they got
to fight the amazon android and then
just when you think they're going to be
able to mend that riff that superman
steads fast so they bring in superman
from an alternate universe and then the
two of them fight and then justice
superman comes out on top but then here
comes lois lane to convince him that
he's wrong and it's and it's just like i
mean it looks like it was a movie that
was written by suits in a board room
right it doesn't look like the injustice
series because it carries none of the
gravitas behind it in all reality that
movie should have been a few movies it
should have been like two or three
movies dc anime has done it before and
that's what's so disappointing about
this because i will always stand by
until such a time that changes i will
always support the idea the dc animated
movies are far and away
much better than the dc live action
movies right the dnc live-action movies
pale in comparison to the animated
movies the animated movies are
phenomenal
if you've never seen them you need to
watch them up until injustice i was
never really disappointed by an animated
movie that they made there were some
questionable choices but by and large
they were just great right the dc
animated films i would say even rival
and in some ways exceed the marvel
cinematic universe but this
it was bad man it was just so
basic and formulaic and boring there was
no point when i was on the edge of my
seat there was no point when it was like
yes thank you like that's what i was
looking for no point when that was the
case it was just kind of like i mean you
know we didn't get to see yellow lantern
superman
[Laughter]
right super superman when he joins the
sinestro corps we never even got to see
that right it was just things like that
it was a hugely missed opportunity and
so having said all of that if you're a
person who never read the injustice
comics series i mean sure i guess you'll
like it but even you might find it just
kind of be like i mean it's pretty basic
and boring if you're a person who read
the injustice comic series it's gonna be
lacking in more than a few ways so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end let me know down in the
comments section what you liked and what
you disliked about the injustice movie
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace